[Musique]
et toujours en politique à moins d'un
mois du premier tour des élections
législatives et ce jusqu'au 12 juin nous
vous proposons de faire le point
circonscription par circonscription sur
ce scrutin à venir à dans les yvelines
wilfrid richy rédacteur en chef de télé
78 c'est avec vous que nous allons
commencer bonsoir anne soir justin ayant
débuté par la première circonscription
forcément montigny le bretonneux
guyancourt la majorité de versailles ça
c'est pour la délimitation géographique
de cette 1ère circonscription des
yvelines je vais vous épargner la
délimitation à la rue près ça prête
forcément à sourire la découpage se fait
ou au milieu d'une commune quoi qu'il en
soit sur le plan électoral est cette
première circonscription a toujours
penché sous la vème république elle vers
la droite vers le centre droit si on
exclut tout de même le scrutin de 2010
est qui a vu donc la victoire de la
république en marche face à l'ump la
victoire de cours d'une courte tête 1 51
06 pour didier baichère contre le
républicain françois-xavier bellamy et
pour cette élection 2022 le casting
change alors tout d'abord exit didier
baichère le sortant pour la majorité
présidentielle c'est une demi surprise
de voir ce marcheur de la première heure
qui s'est notamment attaqué là durant
son mandat au sujet sensible de la
reconnaissance faciale être remplacé une
demi surprise car il le dit lui même il
s'est émancipé une ou deux fois à des
votes de son groupe à l'assemblée il
semble accueillir la nouvelle avec du
recul il soutient ouvertement sur ces
réseaux celui qui briguait sa succession
et il s'appelle charles rodwell et
charles rodwell c'est pas forcément un
nom qui parle à tous les événements
alors charles rolls royce et un adjoint
au maire de versailles chargé de la
jeunesse ils portent l'étiquette
renaissance le nouveau nom de la
république en marche il était depuis l
an dernier conseillant discours pour
bruno le maire parallèlement à sa
carrière chez edf elle si on remonte
encore un peu on constate aussi qu'il a
travaillé aux côtés de franck riester
lorqu'il lorsqu'il était député il fait
donc partie de cette génération de
collaborateurs ministériels macro nist
qui se voient récompensés par des
investitures et récompensé vous l'avez
dit mais ce qu'il pourrait remporter ce
scrutin alors une tâche ou même plus
difficile qu'il n'y paraît déjà parce
qu'en 2017 l'adulte hors cet effet d'une
courte tête et puis dans cette ville de
versailles si on regarde pour les
présidentielles eric zemmour a totalisé
un peu plus de 18% des suffrages dès le
premier tour il est arrivé deuxième
derrière emmanuel macron et puis dans la
ville d'à côté qui fait aussi partie de
cette circonscription celle de
guyancourt jean luc mélenchon lui a
totalisé 35 % et il est arrivé devant
emmanuel macron les deux candidats en
tout cas qui peuvent bénéficier de cet
élan ce sont sébastien ramage pour
lannux lannux plus comme vous voulez
cette alliance et puylaurens trochut
pour reconquête également le premier est
engagé au sein de la france insoumise
conseiller municipal de guyancourt la
seconde a été conseillère départementale
des yvelines jusqu'en 2000 à 21 son
mouvement sens commun qui a été ensuite
rebaptisée mouvement conservateur était
alors alliée avec l'ump depuis lé sa
formation océan pris leurs distances ils
se sont alliés avec eric zemmour après
la défaite d'eric ciotti lors de la
primaire de la droite la frange la plus
dure de la droite on se souvient aussi
que pour ses débuts en politique lance
rochus avait milité au sein de la manif
pour tous et donc elles sont finalement
les autres candidats qui se présentent
dans cette circonscription alors tout
d'abord du côté républicain un autre
conseiller municipal de versailles qui
se présentent olivier de la faire
également au conseiller départemental il
était candidat à l'investiture de son
parti déjà lui en 2017 mais vous l'aviez
compris à l'époque il avait été battu
par françois xavier bellamy qui lui
avait été préféré et puis on notera
aussi la présence d'une candidate du
parti animalistes ou encore d'un
candidat de lutte aux ouvrières et puis
aussi une surprise un pour le
rassemblement national à la candidate
anne jacquemin est épaulé par bruno
gollnisch en tant que suppléant il a
déjà siégé dans l'hémicycle attention
c'était entre 86 et 88 justin pour la
circonscription du rhône il a surtout
été vice président du front national et
puis s était l'artisan de la campagne de
jean-marie le pen en 2002 il est de
retour en politique avec quelques années
de plus en tant que suppléant dans notre
circonscription de versailles là aussi
un parachutage mais ce n'est pas le seul
on pourrait en parler des heures sur
cette antenne aussi en tout cas on en a
parlé pour l'instant et c'est très bien
du coup le scrutin à 12 et 19 juin merci
beaucoup ils quadrillent d'avoir été
avec nous rédacteur en chef de tv 78 et
demain mercredi pocus sur la 2e
circonscription des yvelines dans votre
journal local
[Musique]